these brick buildings in the Liverpool
district of Granby are more than a
century old the city plan to tear them
down but the local residents put up a
fight
five of the houses have already been
renovated by a group of London
architects called assemble they work
with the locals to make the district
more livable and to preserve its unique
character the assemble group was
nominated for a prestigious Turner Prize
this year it's the way in which you
might go about doing up your own house
so if you look at each of the five
houses I've done they're all different
they've all got different extensions
different holes different windows in
them depending on depending on the kind
of life that they'd had before and it's
about not making them generic assemble
decided to preserve as much of the
original construction materials as
possible and that allowed them to keep
the renovation costs down and the team
used those materials in a number of
creative ways
this fireplace is made from material
taken from abandoned houses winter
gardens are to be set up in dilapidated
buildings and local residents have a say
in all of this
well they listened to us and that
changed because nobody really had before
they'd sort of heared us but haven't
listened the Granby project is one of
many that assemble is working on right
now 15 people work here in the Group's
London office they've built the place
themselves there's no boss most of the
staff are in their mid 20s but have
degrees in architecture
we're interested in how everyone can be
part of the built environment and have a
say in how we live and how we build
things I think we are always concerned
with the public space of each project
and whether how accessible what we're
doing is as a process and also as a
final product
they've been commissioned to build
everything from private homes to city
squares right now they're designing a
new gallery for Goldsmith's College in
London I don't think there'll be another
art gallery like it in London the kind
of range of spaces so a lot of the
existing spaces being very left very
very rough and raw and then we're kind
of dropping in some moments of new
structure assemblé was formed in 2010
and promptly turned an abandoned gas
station into a pop-up cinema they
designed theaters one under a freeway
underpass and another at a festival and
were commissioned to breathe new life
into a dreary square in South London we
started working for other architects and
then we felt the frustrated about the
division of tasks and lack of kind of
holistic understanding of a project
I guess we're keen to address the
distance between the way that architects
work on computers and using card and the
way that things are actually being built
physically we just try an experiment
whenever we can where appropriate so we
do a lot of kind of concrete casting and
mixing and color playing with color lot
here's a work studio located next to
assembles office the facade consists of
specially laid concrete tiles the
exterior is colourful but the interior
design is simple architecture buffs
travel to the site to study the building
and take pictures
the team from assemble built a small
concert hall in an empty space in the
London borough of Hackney
the walls are made of rubble that was
found nearby
assemblé tries to do more with less and
to use local building materials whenever
possible it's also important to work
with the people who live in the
neighborhood
there is a kind of spirit here and
despite how much it's it's people try
and crush it you know it kind of is
still here I